فكره جديده مبتكره لمحاربه سرطان الجلد
تقوم على انتاج جلد الصناعي لاختباره ومنه
يمكن دراسه وقف تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه
الخبيثه هذا الجل الاصطناعي اقرب ما يمكن
لبشره الانسان الحقيقيه بخلايا الجلديه
مزروعه من ماده الكولاجين
بحسب ما جاء في مجله ساين سيغنينج فانه
جرى اختبار بعضها على البشر وبعدها قيد
الاختبار فيما يتعلق
في الباحثون وهم علماء في جامعه كوبنهاجن
سعوا في دراستهم الى معرفه ما يحدث على
وجه التحديد عندما تتحول خليه طبيعيه الى
سرطانيه وكيفيه السيطره عليها
[موسيقى]
الدكتور عندما نتحدث عن انتاج جلد اصطناعي
قادر على منع تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه الى
طبقات الجلد نتحدث عن اهميه هذا الابتكار
وما هو الجلد الاصطناعي للناس اللي عم
تشوفنا كيف يمكن ترويضه طبيا بالبدايه قبل
ما ابدا بالجلد الاصطناعي لازم نشرح شو
متكون هاي الجلد هو متكون من طبقات وتلات
طبقات اساسيه للجلد يعني عنا البشره
للتحمينا من كل شيء خارج وما يفوت لجوا
الطبقه الثانيه في الاوعيه الدمويه اللي
بتغذي البشره وكل باقي الجلد اخر طبقه
فيها الدهون اللي هي بتحمل
الاعضاء الداخليه من اذا صار صدمه او صار
غيره فبس بدنا نيجي ندرس بالمختبر الجلد
ما فينا نفصل بس طبقه واحده عن البقيه
فينا ندرس وبالعاده
كنا ندرس وين على مسطحات بلاستيكيه فبس
فينا ندرس جزء من طبقه واحده بهاي الحاله
استعملوا هول العلماء كلها هي ماده موجوده
كثير بجسمنا اكثر بروتين موجود وحطوا هول
الطبقات الجلد اللي هي بتمثل حقيقه شو
موجود بجسم الانسان من خلالها درسوا
مسارات بتكونها الخلايا لتصير خلايا
سرطانيه وبتعمل غزوه لباقي الطبقات لانه
بالعاده الخلايا الموجوده بطبقه ما مفروض
تغذي الطبقه الثانيه بس خلايا السرطانيه
ما عندها هيدا ما عندها هيدا السلوك
بتتمدد وبتنتشر بكل
تمدد الخلايا السرطانيه بس مش بنقدر نقول
علاج لسرطان الجلد يعني كعلاج ثوري لا مش
علاج هن درسوها لانه اكتشفوا بهول
المسارات بس بس يتفعل هو بيوقف هذا التمدد
فيوقف هذا التمدد ايوه نوع من الحلول هو
يمكن بالسرطان بيتم توقيفه لهيدا المسار
اعاده تفعيل واعطاء ادويه لاعاده تفعيله
فهون الخليه السرطانيه ما بتقعد تتمدد
بباقي الطبقات الجلديه بنوقف من انتشاره
للسرطان
[موسيقى]